pure self recognition and absolute
otherness this ether is such is the
ground in soil of science or knowledge
in general the beginning of philosophy
presupposes or requires that
consciousness should dwell in this
element but this element itself achieves
its own perfection and transparency only
through the movement of its becoming it
is pure spirituality is the universal
that has the form of simple immediacy
this simple being in its existential
form is the soil of science it is
thinking which has its being in spirit
alone because this element this
immediacy of spirit is the very
substance of spirit it is the
transfigured essence reflection which is
itself simple and which is for itself
immediacy as such being that is
reflected into itself science on its
part requires that self-consciousness
should have raised itself into this
ether in order to be able to live and
actually to live with science and in
science conversely the individual has
the right to demand that science should
at least provide him with the ladder to
the stand point should show him the
stand point within himself his right is
based on his absolute independence which
he is conscious of possessing in every
phase of his knowledge for in each one
whether recognized by science or not and
whatever the content may be the
individual is the absolute form that is
he is the immediate certainty of himself
and if this expression be preferred he
is therefore unconditioned being the
standpoint of consciousness which knows
objects and their antithesis to itself
in itself an antithesis to them it is
for science the antithesis of its own
standpoint the situation in which
consciousness knows itself to be at home
is for science one marked by the absence
of spirit
conversely the element of science is for
consciousness a remote beyond in which
it no longer possesses itself each of
these two aspects of self conscious
spirit appears to the other is the
inversion of truth when natural
consciousness and trust itself
straightaway to science it makes an
attempt induced by it knows not what to
walk on its head to just this once the
compulsion to assume this unwanted
posture and to go about it go about in
it is a violence it is expected to do to
itself all unprepared and seemingly
without necessity let science be in its
own self what it may relatively to
immediate self consciousness it presents
itself in an inverted posture or because
this self consciousness has the
principle of its actual existence in the
certainty of itself science appears to
it not to be actual since self
consciousness exists on its own account
outside of science science must
therefore unite this element of self
certainty with itself or rather show
that and how this element belongs to it
so long as science lacks this actual
dimension it is only the content as the
in itself the purpose that is as yet
still something inward not yet spirit
but only spiritual substance this in
itself has to express itself outwardly
and become for itself and this means
simply that it has to posit
self-consciousness as one with itself
section 26 is a lengthy passage in which
there's a lot of terms being used and
there's a lot going on at first it's a
little bit murky about exactly what Hale
is trying to get at and you can easily
get lost I think upon a first a second a
third after years of reading in this
particular passage and this is another
one of those important turning points as
we'll see as we move on to section 27
where what he's talking about here is
going to become very explicit in what
it's really about so he talks at first
about pure self recognition as being an
absolute otherness as being this ether
this medium for science and you notice
that I've got science here and then the
individual and there's going to be an
interplay going on throughout this
entire section between the individual
and science when we see individual we
should think actually about ourselves as
individual subjects as individual people
with our own histories as concretely
existing a little bit later we're going
to talk about the the concrete universal
and the universal individual and but for
the time being just think about
individual in terms of the kind of
individuals that we know it's very
important I think in this section once
again I see in comments that people are
getting a little bit confused about what
Hegel means by science and they are
trying to transpose contemporary you
know conceptions of science which are a
little bit more truncated than what
Hegel means he means something that's
broader than natural science broader
than what we teach in in high schools or
colleges as the scientific method there
are actually more than once I
he's talking about a systematic body of
knowledge and he thinks that it's at the
very heart of the needs within science
and the very nature of science that not
only does it need to be systematic not
only does it have to attempt to try to
verify things but it has to be reflexive
it has to be thinking about itself that
is actually adequate to reality which
includes itself as part of that reality
and that's where Hegel's viewpoint on
science is in many respects radically
different from that of many
practitioners of science and then we
what we might call the popularizers and
arguers with reference to science and
indeed science sciences modern sciences
apologists because quite often although
science is extremely good at some things
science again now in the modern
non-hague Elian sense it tends to be a
little bit blind to what it's about
blind to its own limits blind to what
would be required in order for it to
actually address those limits that is
what Hegel is trying to get at in this
section and indeed throughout the entire
phenomenology so let's look now at what
he says he says the beginning of
philosophy presupposes it requires a
consciousness should well in this
element and so we want to think of this
as sort of the baseline this element
we've explored this already pure self
recognition and absolute otherness what
what do we mean by that well everything
contains within itself a sort of non
simpleness everything is related to
something and when we're dealing with
human beings and human realities that
relatedness takes place through what
Hegel is called being in itself and
being for itself
and the fact that these two kind of are
you know flip sides of the same coin so
my thinking of something is already
relatedness to that thing that I am
thinking I'm over here or do you gonna
need some spatial metaphors that thing
is over here and we're somehow connected
through the act of thinking and the act
of thinking is something which works
upon that object I am the subject in
that case doing that now if I become
aware of my own limitations in doing
that I actually shift vantage point and
say I need to be adequate to this object
the object is now supplying me with
criteria which are now judging my own
act capacity performance I become an
object to myself I've become being in
and for itself in the process so there
is nothing simple in the Galleon
dialectics or you might say whatever it
is truly truly simple is so so simple as
to not be worth even talking about we're
we're really interested in is how the
interest how the things that are complex
connect with each other what they unfold
into so he says this element itself okay
once again this element is consciousness
achieves its own perfection and
transparency only through the movement
of its becoming it's not what it's going
to be from the start it's not perfect in
its inception it's not fully realized
that takes labor that takes what we call
the patience and labour of the negative
earlier so he says this simple being in
its existential form is the soil of
science and now we support just two
talking about spirits Geist mind along
with this goes the notion of activity of
taking things in and working upon a
unifying them so he says this element
this immediacy of spirit is the very
substance of spirit is the transfigured
essence reflection which is a
self simple and witches for itself
immediacy as such we're getting to the
individual being that is reflected into
itself so we're starting to move towards
this not I don't say category this poll
of the antithesis is going to be taking
place so science on its part requires
that self consciousness should have
raised itself in order to be able to
live with science and in science
conversely and now he's introducing a
dialectic between the individual and
science conversely the individual has
the right to demand from science this is
a very interesting notion the individual
exists whether science exists or not as
it turns out science actually does exist
science is actually out there at least
in potential and you know in our lives
in the actuality we come into a world
that has already you know got all sorts
of fragments of what would be a galleon
of un science already active being
worked out you know in textbooks in
procedures we have products of that
through technology but the individual
has a sort of radical freedom visa v
scientific knowledge systematic
understanding of things if we want to be
facetious about this we can say the
individual can say screw you I don't
need to study you
many of us have familiarity with that
having taught undergraduates where we
have to make the case to them what is
this good for why do I need to know this
how is this going to actually tie into
my world my concerns my interests how
will this scientific knowledge actually
provide me with something that I myself
need so he says science
requires that self consciousness should
have raised itself and the individual
has the right to demand that science
should at least provide him with the
ladder to that standpoint science needs
to show the individual how to get its
way back to science that means the
science has to provide the individual
with some sort of conception of what is
over here what is exceeding the
intellectual standpoint or even the
practical standpoint that the individual
is already engaged in with the the
environment with other people what is
this going to bring to the table what is
it to use of William James Ian's phrase
cash value so it should show him this
standpoint now notice what Hegel says
should show him the standpoint within
himself oftentimes when we want to teach
some sort of disciplinary knowledge
don't even worry about Sciences per se
just think about disciplinary knowledge
more broadly where there's some sort of
principles to begin with there has been
a development of the body of knowledge
it can be taught it can be worked out
there can be a sort of sequence by which
a person can learn to grasp more and
more complex things whenever we have
that there's always this danger of sort
of trying to impose it on a person and
say look you just need to learn this and
you need to adapt yourself to yet don't
worry about whether it has any way of
meeting you where you are now we can go
way too far with this and swing to the
other extreme and totally
instrumentalize disciplinary knowledge
and say well you know unless it really
appeals to you little so-and-so it's no
good and in fact it's interesting to see
the discussions that have taken place
recently in terms of the American Common
Core and mathematics and how mathematics
ought to be taught there is actually
something to be said
for telling kids hey do the problems
learn the stuff and then we'll talk
about applications and there's been this
swinging to the other extremum well we
got to start with applications because
that's going to get them interested and
it'll situate them and you know hanger
would actually say yeah you need both
sides too much of what is bad too much
of the other is bad there needs to be an
interplay dynamic interplay between them
so science ought to supply that to the
individual and here's where Hegel begins
to introduce you notice I've got this
term antithesis thrown all over the
place here the individual is the
immediate certainty of himself that
means that we actually know that we
exist
we like it or not can't get away from
ourselves
not for long at least and we're aware
that we're engaged of things we're aware
that we have the history we're aware
that we face concrete problems so we
have immediate certainty of ourselves
and we are therefore Hegel says if you
like this way of saying an unconditioned
being for each one of our cells we kind
of feel unnaturally because this is the
nature of consciousness like we are at
the center of things and everything
exists in relation to us it is for us
whereas we are to a certain degree
unconditioned in ourselves now we can
lose sight of that very quickly just go
to work only you realize you're not the
center of the universe because you have
to you know punch a clock or put up with
people's be ass or who knows then you
don't have immediate certainty of
yourself at that moment but but it
restores you get off work get home our
homes are where you know we turn these
into places that are supposed to be
reflections of our importance our
centrality then we get very upset when
people mess them up right or when we
have to hear our neighbor and their
their nonsense down the road so he says
the standpoint of consciousness which
knows objects
in their antithesis to itself and itself
in antithesis the objects now into this
is opposition as being other the objects
are something different from the self
this truck is different from me as a
matter of fact my clothing is something
different from me right and Fitness's
try not to get yourself caught up in the
the thesis into this a synthesis you
know everyone wants to make Hegel into a
constant triangle because that would
actually be out of place here he's
interested in these these antitheses and
he says look individuals exist in
relation to their environments which
they are to a certain degree superior to
but they're also conditioned by and
those you know they don't determine us
in the sense of like make us do or make
us think exactly what we are because we
do have some degree of freedom but they
do condition us and we condition them in
turn and it's individuated your
environment although we may share it is
not exactly the same thing as mine
here's a very concrete example of this
I'm 6 foot 3 tall and that means that
I'm taller than most people watching
this video those who I'm not taller than
those who are taller than me they
actually wind up having to you know
stoop as they go into doorways the the
environment is somewhat different for
them I have to watch it when it comes to
short doorways because I can hit my head
on them and this sounds like a very
trivial thing but if you're five foot
six that's not an issue for you you
relate to objects at least in that
respect differently than do I on the
other hand I have no problem getting
things down from shelves or if I do that
is indeed a very high shelf well you
know somebody who's 5 foot 2 experiences
the high shelf and the things on it in a
somewhat different way so notice now
Hegel talks about the antithesis
of science to this there's an antithesis
to the antitheses that exists that way
why because science should be objective
Universal not tied down to the
perspective of one particular individual
or even a group of individuals that's
the promise of knowledge and so he says
there's an antithesis there as well
science understands that to be the
antithesis of its own standpoint and
notice that both of these science by the
way is the in itself into the
individuals the for itself in this
respect both of these see the other as
lacking spirit or spirituality or a
steatite mentality intellectually we
might say reason ability rationality and
both of them are partly right so he says
each of these two aspects of self
conscious spirit appears to the other is
the inversion of truth for the
individual there are some things at
least at this point in development where
I can say science doesn't get this you
know I go to the doctor the doctor looks
at me
through the lens of medical science and
says you need to lose weight and I say
well yeah I know I do but here's why
it's hard I'm doing all this work and
it's hard to get to the gym and exercise
that's me in my own little personal
world and the doctor can say well sure
you've got your own personal little
stuff but look if you don't lose the
weight you're gonna get the diabetes and
you're not gonna like that because then
you're gonna have to take insulin and
eventually you might even die of it or
lose your feet or you know stuff like
that and the doctor was trying to you
know sort of make it
existencial for me my butt scaring me
with these things but he might actually
say well I could say I could respond and
say well a lot of people are fat and
they don't get diabetes and said well
statistically here is what we actually
know and now he's working within the
realm of something which transcends the
individual but also in a certain respect
doesn't appeal to the individual and the
individual the existential pole of this
can say to science well you're lacking a
certain aspect of truth but science can
say that to the individual so these are
not reconciled yet the antithesis is
still their spirit he says is they
actually split into these two sides of
the individual and science which are not
reconciled so he says when natural
consciousness and trust itself
straightaway to science it makes an
attempt to walk on its head but you know
it doesn't doesn't really work very far
you can't get very far walking on your
head the compulsion to assume this
unwanted posture is a violence that's
it's expected to do to itself and this
is something that students experience
when they're trying to learn some new
disciplinary knowledge think about
trying to learn a language and trying to
wrap your tongue around it and then
trying to memorize this stuff and I know
there's other ways to learn languages as
well but just go with me on this so
you're trying to wrap your head around
these these foreign you know ways of
thinking about things declining nouns
and conjugating verbs and talking about
the subjunctive or you know depending on
what language it is adapting yourself to
that feels kind of painful at first it
feels unnatural but that's part of
what's required on the other hand if
disciplinary knowledge is to really be
what it wants to be it has to take into
account the individual
it has to become more flexible than it
is this is again why Hegelian science
would be something quite different than
what we often term science so he says
let science be in its own self what it
may relative to immediate
self-consciousness it prevents that it
presents itself in an inverted posture
or because this self-consciousness has
the principal of its actual existence in
the certainty of itself science appears
to it not to be actual and again a
common thing you've got your book
learning but I've got actual experience
because science doesn't experience
individuals experience science can only
be derived and develop through actually
having individual people who become
scientists so this leads us to where we
really want to go we have the moment of
you know clash and under familiarity so
he says science must therefore unite
this element to self certainty with
itself or rather show that and how this
element belongs to it implicitly it's
already there so long as science lacks
this actual dimension it is only the
content as the in itself it is the
objective but that's it it may have
predictive power and may be able to
classify things but it's not
consciousness yet until it's
appropriated by individual consciousness
so he says this in itself has to express
itself outwardly and become for itself
this means simply it has to posit
self-consciousness as one with itself so
now we want to think about how that's
actually going to happen